hi this is Prussia talker in this video
I'm going to explain a weird way that
you can multiply numbers known as the
Egyptian method or Russian peasant
multiplication the interesting aspect is
that you will be able to multiply any
two whole numbers as long as you know
how to divide numbers in half and double
numbers so let's do an example of 13
times 24 the method involves 4 steps the
first step is to take the number on the
left and repeatedly divide it in half
until you get to the number 1 so we'll
take 13 when we divide that in half we
get 6 and we'll ignore the remainder
when we divide 6 and a half we get 3 and
when we get divided 3 and a half we get
1 and we'll ignore the remainder of 1 so
the first step is to take the number on
the left and repeatedly divide it in
half the second step is to take the
number on the right and keep doubling it
so the number 24 when doubled is 48 then
we're going to double this number again
to get 96 and finally we double 96 to
get 192 the third step is to modify our
table by crossing out any row that
starts with an even number in our table
only the row that starts out with 6 is
an even number so we're going to cross
out the entire row the final step is to
add the numbers in the right-hand column
so we need to add up 24 96 and 192 and
when we do that we get the result of 312
and that's our answer
13 times 24 is 312 let's do another
example to see how this method works
let's say you wanted to do 16 times 26
the first step is to divide the number
on the left in half repeatedly
so dividing 16 and 1/2 we get 8 and then
4 2 and finally 1 we take the number on
the right and we repeatedly double it so
from 26 we get 52 104 208 and 416 the
third step is to cross out any row in
our table that starts with an even
number and in this table we have a lot
of even numbers so we cross out the
first row the second row the third and
the fourth row the only road that
remains is the last row and so that's
our answer 416 and in fact 16 times 26
is 416 so the short reason this method
works is we're doing multiplication in
binary the long answer I provided a link
in the video description I hope you
liked this video please subscribe to my
channel you can catch around my blog
mind your decisions or on twitter at
presto locker